foreign
holy cow people we are live on the
Internet or as some of you call it the
World Wide Web that means the
government's watching us and joining me
today is the host of John Bachmann now
on Newsmax TV John Bachman cleverly
named show right there an associate
editor of the Claremont Institute host
of The Young Heretics show and author of
how to save the West Spencer Clavin guys
welcome back to the Reuben report great
to see you Dave great to see Andrew
we've got a Newsmax guy and a daily wire
guy I sense they'll be jockeying for
position throughout the show uh but what
we're going to do what we're going to do
today is a recap of just some some of
the craziness this week that's what I
try to do on uh on Fridays here the big
thing this week sort of in the culture
wars was that Dylan Mulvaney a name that
none of us should know but for some
reason all of us do know uh who is the
guy who transitioned I suppose to a
woman it's unclear to me whether that
involved the all of the full transition
if you know what I mean uh but he or she
is getting sponsorships from major major
corporations the big one being Bud Light
who put his or her name on a can and it
has cost Bud Light about seven billion
dollars that's billion with a B uh in
market cap since this began here's Dylan
talking about the partnership with Bud
Light hi
carrying skills right I got some Bud
Lights for us so I kept hearing about
this thing called March Madness and I
thought we were all just having a hectic
month but it turns out it has something
to do with sports and I'm not sure
exactly which sport but either way it's
a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love you okay break a leg we
you know given the devil his due I have
to say his comic timing is not terrible
there's something sort of amusing there
if he would say I am a guy dressed up as
a woman pretending to be the worst
stereotype possible of a woman that
might actually be something that would
be remotely funny that has nothing to do
with what's going on here Spencer am I
being too judgmental am I being
transphobic and uh what about seven
billion dollars in market cap loss that
ain't chump change no I think you're
being pretty generous and I agree you
know every time I actually watch this
guy I think you know he's pretty funny
and he's a kind of guy that I generally
sort of like he's your stereotypical
Garden variety theater kid gay guy you
know everybody's known this dude at some
point in high school and one of the
things that actually makes me most upset
about this new kind of trans extremism
everywhere everything is always trans
right uh is that that kind of guy the
tomboys of the world the boys and girls
that don't perfectly fit into this
bizarre stereotype of what men and women
are which is the trans movements fantasy
those guys are now getting you know sort
of LED down this weird Garden Path and I
wish Dave that I didn't know the answer
to your question about bottom surgery
but I actually feel like based on
another sponsorship that this guy's got
with Nike yeah which had him wearing
these incredibly tight leggings I
actually think I do know the answer that
question I'm going to leave that there
and simply say the whole thing of
shoving this in people's faces obviously
it's hugely unpopular it loses money
every time they do it so it's clearly
meant to portray a certain idea about
Boyhood girlhood what you can be and
should be and the people that should be
most angry about it honestly are gay
people who are getting caricatured out
of existence
um so that now a guy that grows up like
Dylan has to put on a wig and pretend to
be a girl just to get noticed it's
incredibly sad gay people wait wait hold
on one second just to be clear I think
what you're saying is that Dylan still
does have a wang
I am not going to ask my guys to Google
it because we didn't do it yesterday and
I thought maybe for the first time in
months we could do two shows
consecutively where we wouldn't have to
Google who has a wang I implore
lunchtime yeah all right yeah Bachmann
let's not do that Bachman you're you're
a news guy you're an actual news guy an
anchor of really my favorite of all of
all the daytime shows my favorite show
to go on and you have to cover this
stuff constantly but I know you really
care about real news how do you blend
that those two things
that's a great question because there is
a lot of real news to talk about here
you guys mentioned the uh Financial uh
downside of this for Bud Light and then
there's also I think questions we can
ask Anheuser-Busch about the management
from what I'm reading today is that
senior level managers at Anheuser-Busch
did not know that this was happening and
you have this vice president who's
facing some criticism for making this
decision she clearly doesn't understand
the audience uh the the consumer base at
Anheuser-Busch uh making this decision
and what appears to be something that
was small and supposed to be contained
sending Dylan Mulvaney these cans of Bud
Light It was supposed to be the digital
uh thing but it's turned into this
monster that continues to metastasize in
a way that Anheuser-Busch can't get
their arms around it is this vice
president going to be fired are there
going to be changes inside
Anheuser-Busch there's all that stuff to
talk about and then to what Andrew
Andrew's point before I think is very
important is how this transgender
movement is as some people say it does
appear to act like a social contagion
the average drama a club gay dude that
we all knew in high school it does now
seem to be in encouraged financially and
other we for other reasons as well to
pursue this transgenderism and when you
look at the Hard statistics associated
with the trends the the number of of uh
kids saying that there are now
transgender they don't feel comfortable
in their own bodies it's just like to me
you guys remember when we were all in
school and one person would come back
from the lunchroom and say oh I'm Atomic
my stomach hurts I need to go home that
person goes home and then like five
other kids in the class say oh me too I
have food poisoning and I need to go
home too they get it's a moral hazard
this whole thing creates for kids
God I quickly want to point out that
Spencer does have a striking resemblance
to Andrew Clavin but that is Spencer
Clavin I believe you're related I
believe they are related somehow totally
related to one another
slip it's a Freudian slip I should yeah
just kidding I'm sorry big fan of your
dad's big fan of your dads me too and
happy honor to be confused with him but
I will just say in response to what you
said at the end there you know as
somebody who can quote every Steven
Sondheim lyric basically from memory I
shudder to think what would have
happened to a kid like me in high school
if I had been born just 10 years later
you're exactly right the way this acts
as a contagion the minute anybody says
anything even remotely out of this
narrow box you get sucked into it
it seems to me that the the G's are at
complete odds now with the t's but let's
jump because John you mentioned it we
played this video yesterday a portion of
it this is the VP of marketing at Bud
Light her name is Alicia heinerscheid
talking about why she did this in the
first place and without leading too much
I mean tell me is this someone who's
really trying to sell product or trying
to push an agenda I'm a businesswoman I
had a really clear job to do when I took
over Bud Light and it was this brand is
in Decline it's been in Decline for a
really long time and if we do not
attract young drinkers to come and drink
this brand there will be no future for
Bud Light so I had this super clear
mandate it's like we need to evolve and
Elevate this incredibly iconic brand and
my what I brought to that was a belief
in okay what is what what does evolve
and elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone it means having
a campaign that's truly inclusive and
feels lighter and brighter and different
and appeals to women and to men and
representation is it sort of the heart
of evolution you've got to see people
who reflect you in the work and we had
this hangover I mean Bud Light had been
kind of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
I got to give her a little bit of credit
for the Candor there basically saying I
personally don't like the people who
drink this beer and thus we are going to
make other people drink it I mean John
you know I'm a tequila guy and whenever
you come over you do bring a fancy
bottle and I appreciate it uh but it's
it's almost it's kind of offensive to
the people who actually buy the beer
isn't it I think so and what I think is
also why does Anheuser-Busch in this
multinational corporation in bed have
like 7 000 Brands can't they Custom
Tailor one of the other brands to reach
this audience these people aren't gonna
drink but Dylan Mulvaney doesn't drink
Bud Light you can tell the second it
hits her lips she's never tasted a Bud
Light before in her life nor does she
enjoy the taste of Bud Light they have
Bud Light Seltzer they have all kinds of
stuff we could bring back bud dry guys
remember Bud dry or some other sort of
beer they could make it up it just it
boggles the mind and it just goes back
to what I think is a deeper problem in
Corporate America is you have
organizations like the Human Rights
Council which is funded by the open
society's foundation and George Soros
they are the ones setting the tone it's
not about the fiduciary responsibility
or the the the the the responsibility of
these corporations to their shareholders
and their employees of the company who
might lose out on this it's really about
well what is what is you know the gay
Mafia going to say about our advertising
campaign that's really what matters
first and pardon the pun here putting
the heart before the cart before the
horse they are putting this card before
those Clydesdale horses which are also
now apparently in Jeopardy as a result
of this poor marketing decision oh no
are they not going to feed the horses
what are you saying are they sending
them there have been threats now against
the Clydesdale horses maybe a false flag
threat who knows but still they're happy
to they're having to make sure this the
safety of these horses is is Paramount
because they they still care about that
I guess an American icon the Clydesdale
horses so uh Spencer to John's Point
wouldn't it if they really if if this
woman really cared about this branding
exercise that she's going through
wouldn't what John said be the right
thing to do which is okay we could add
another vertical to the amount of beers
we have we have four jillion beers and
seltzers and vodka this and all that add
one and and actually nobody you know
there would have been a little online
you know whatever about it but it
wouldn't have been this this thing about
going after an iconic brand like it was
going after Diet Coke or something no no
that's part of the point they can't just
make something new they do this with
movies too they don't just make a new
story about a superhero that fits this
particular demographic they have to take
the superhero you love the classic the
Supermans and the Batmans of the world
and turn it into a kind of idol a sort
of you know an image of their own stupid
ideology because that's part of the
message the message is not just
inclusion the message is we're coming
for you we're coming to uh appropriate
and and re-create transform from
everything that you know and love so
you're right I mean I'm sitting here
trying to think like what the new Bud
Light product would be that represents
Dylan Mulvaney specifically like Bud and
Coke Fireball bud but anyway I mean
without getting it like into too many of
the stereotypes that I've just been
joking about I do think you know that
you mentioned my association with the
daily wire and I love those guys one of
the things that we've seen is you know
back when Hershey's did something very
similar had a transgender you know he
she uh chocolate bar and people got up
in arms the next day I kid you not I
walked into the daily wire offices and
it was like Willy Wonka's pop-up shop
they had transformed themselves into a a
chocolate company and there's an
enormous market for that because they
know who they're selling to they don't
hate the people that buy their products
they actually like them they want to
cater to their interests and get money
in return that's capitalism whatever
that woman said is not capitalism and
Ben Shapiro is the size of of an Oompa
Loompa so there you go well I also love
I love I love what they've done with the
razors too the the flip side of that
though for me is when you don't have
something in common with somebody you
that's the type of stuff before it was
politicized you walk up to a bar and
maybe I might have a conversation with a
transgender dude or transgender woman
and say oh you like Bud Light me too and
that's the one thing that we could have
in common and maybe you could have that
if this was done a different way but
we're all separating into our own Brands
we have our own identities now and as
much as I think that's necessary based
on what's happening with corporate
America I do wonder about the long-term
effect of that and for our country and
our society I agree with you it's really
sad that this is something which has to
be done in order for people to just even
feel I mean it's like ethically sourced
conservative products you know we're not
supposed to do anything right that want
that right but what is a single Source
conservative media that's right it comes
from the pure like streams of
ideological Excellence but but what I
suspect is actually the cases we push
forward in this direction and really try
to offer to America the stories and the
products and the advertisements and the
brands that people genuinely want that
connect them to their sense of
patriotism that enable them to love
their country again and think of their
just basic normal families as like
basically good and a good thing to do I
think that's actually a huge tent I
don't think that ultimately this is an
attempt to Silo people off into some
conservative brand this is to say the
conservative brand is the brand now it's
the thing that you you know it is the
brand that if you don't want to be like
kind of hacked into bits and pumped full
of hormones just because you like
skateboards instead of dresses or
whatever then come over to us you know
it used to be that conservatism was you
know a particular set of ideological
commitments it still is those but those
commitments now basically just amount to
recognizing reality and that's right yes
that is the point it when people always
say to me Dave how can you call yourself
a conservative with with some of your
views and it's like well if you
basically believe in reality right we're
pretty much in that thing that's what it
is and by the way that's why what you
guys are doing of daily wire is blowing
up it's exactly why we uh built locals
in Rumble that we will build new things
and they're not just for us they're for
everybody and they will be better but
let's move on because the other uh big
story this week of course was uh what
happened at the Tennessee Capitol and
these three uh lawmakers who got booted
because they broke some of the rules by
bringing in bullhorns and protesters
that weren't supposed to be there and
everything else uh two of them were then
suspended they've all been unsuspended
subsequently uh we played a video
yesterday or the last couple days this
guy Justin Pearson with his fake uh MLK
accent the other guy who's gone a little
under the radar uh is uh who is this
sorry this is Justin Jones oh the
virtually they're both Justin it's
Justin Pearson suggestions boy and my
son's Justin this is weird uh Justin
Jones is the other guy uh here's Justin
Jones with his own fake accent
explaining uh well his political
philosophy I suppose
simply because you have the numbers to
do it
if I didn't know this was happening to
us
and I read the news three opposition
legislators expelled from the
legislature I would think that this was
another Nation
but no
is Tennessee
[Music]
is no more
John as a newsman you have to talk with
a certain Cadence but what is with these
people who do these fake accents and
then they're off camera and they sound
like regular people can you tell me what
that's about
I I always try to give people a little
Grace and I said this week on my show
that it's true I do not sound like I
sounded in college and what changed is
that I'm on camera all the time and you
but the thing is is I don't care what he
says on camera it doesn't match what he
says off camera that's that has always
been the test of a really successful or
a quality news person in my mind you see
him on camera and then you meet him in
person is it the same person there's an
authenticity Gap in this country I talk
about it all the time uh the other guy
Justin Pearson is the one whose Clips
have gone viral or he sounds
um like you know a speech coach almost
in college and now he's talking about a
black Jesus he's got an afro and he's
certainly changed I mean that's what
happens when you get into politics right
people start to influence you you very
rarely see leaders in this country that
get into politics and remain true to
their core ideals some people change and
they change for different reasons
because of lobbyists because of
different interests I I certainly think
these guys are playing to the field so
to speak they know what Their audience
and what the mainstream media for the
most part is going to eat up and what
really bothers me about this story from
you know if you look at this through a
republican lens you've got to be
frustrated because what happened in
Tennessee was actually some I think some
pretty important legislation passed in
terms of keeping schools safe the end
result is that these two Justins now are
National figures you better believe
they're going to get featured speaking
roles at the Democratic National
Convention in Chicago I mean there's
probably people trying to build them up
to be the next Barack Obama no kidding
right now so this is what the Republican
Party does they do something substantial
and good like pass this legislation they
get mired in these types of debates and
this kind of chicanery and I and on the
on the merits I agree with what the
Republicans did you can't have people
disrupting public you know regular
course of business with bullhorns but
you always got to think about what I
always call Dave the third rule of
politics just like Newton's third law of
physics in physics it's for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
in politics for every action there's a
completely opposite and disproportional
response to what you think is going to
happen and Republicans seem to have
forgotten that to that point Spencer is
this one of those things where okay if
everyone I don't think anyone's debating
or questioning whether they broke the
rules they broke the rules everyone's
accepting it to me even though I get
John's point you have to suspend them
because we either have rules or we don't
that's like a trump you know you have a
country or you don't
but I still understand the second order
of this stuff which is that Optics wise
it somehow makes all of Tennessee look
racist because the two black guys got
suspended they're back in by the way
yeah almost immediately I mean in part
because of this enormous you know news
kerfuffle that kicked up around them
look here's what I'd say about that I I
agree when you can't just let people
interrupt every possible rule of decorum
and procedure and let that slide
especially when conservatives
Republicans are getting hammered every
day about what happened on January 6.
you should be able to say well well you
know what one set of rules for the whole
country or or none but I do think that
Republicans have to catch wise to the
fact that they are not going to be
treated fairly they're not going to be
treated fairly in the news media they're
not going to be treated fairly even you
know in in the federal government like
we've known this for a long time now at
least since 2020 and really we should
have known it for decades more than that
so we ought to be ready for it we ought
to be prepared I mean These Guys these
these two Justins they are rhetorically
prepared in a way that Republicans don't
seem to be because they're doing this
act it definitely is an act people talk
about code switching whatever it's
obviously a sham and a phony I mean
Justin Pearson's actually quite eloquent
Justin Jones sounds like he's just
trying to think about what he's going to
say next he's like and I am very he
sounds he sounds like the old SNL uh
Jesse Jackson character that that's who
he sounds like right but this is here's
an important thing though who's the
audience for this shtick it's white
people it's nice liberal white ladies I
mean this is something that PG Keenan
made this point in the Federalists that
this is not like a kind of authenticity
that's welling up from his you know time
in the black church or something this is
a it's an expressly woke appeal to white
women and men who want to excuse their
guilt and it's working great I mean it's
incredibly cynical Ploy but I think the
Republicans can get a little more shrewd
about how this stuff tends to work all I
know is I hope this really is is an
adjusting thing because if I'm ever
feeding Justin and he looks at me and
he's like you think I got ta listen to
you mother we're gonna have
a real problems
father to another that someday will
happen I promise you you just have to be
ready for it let me show you one other
thing on Justin Jones because he's also
making it sound like he's always been
this peaceful guy and he's never done
anything wrong and it's only because of
racism they're going after him but let's
play this video it's b-roll so there's
no audio so I could talk over it for a
minute this is in the summer of love
2020. when we were all supposed to be
locked home uh you know making sure we
didn't get covered that is Justin Jones
in the Hat right there approaching uh
the car so they're blocking the road
he's one of the people blocking the road
there you can see on the other side of
the street watch this guy with his
little fake fall come over there and how
he's gonna oh I'm out but watch Justin
Jones he's kind of going yelling at the
guy in the car and he's sick in his hand
in the car this guy's probably just got
a truck there he's probably just trying
to go to work now he's taking a traffic
cone and he's sticking it in the car and
he's gonna throw it at the driver who's
driving away that is very peaceful
Justin Jones Spencer I'm guessing uh
that's probably not the only time he's
done something like that I mean I'm out
here I'm actually in Nashville right now
I'm like Looking Out My Window as you're
talking to see if mostly peaceful
Justice is about to come knocking on my
door for like you know for broadcasting
evil thoughts and opinions no I mean
this is part of that inconsistency that
at this point we should be used to and
understand that it's always going to be
baked into this Elite cake they get to
do insurrections we don't right that's
how this works if if we even step a
moment out of line it's effectively the
reichstag fire and Trump is Hitler and
everything needs to come crashing down
to persecute these people to the
furthest extent of the law and Beyond
right we need to indict Trump we need to
do all these things um now when the left
Riots of course it's mostly peaceful
it's there's a little arson there's a
little property damage here and there
but really these are civil rights Heroes
and so we ought to excuse them I mean
that is expressly the ideology at at
work here so it shouldn't surprise us I
don't think
bring us home on this one on the double
standards part of this do we just all
have to get over it
no we don't have to get over it we have
to continue to point out the facts here
and that's that's the way we went and I
was going to say you know we don't want
to fall on the same trap that Democrats
do when they compare January 6 to Pearl
Harbor and 9 11 and everything else I
mean we can say this stuff is is not
right but you know what happened in
Tennessee disruptive of course illegal
perhaps were they Justified and
suspending on based on what happened I
believe so but it wasn't an Insurrection
and we have to stick to the facts and
point out that when people are not
arrested like Justin Jones in that video
for assault which he should have been or
maybe even aggravated assault because he
was a traffic cone or when Riley Gaines
goes to San Francisco and people detain
her in a classroom and the
administrators of the school are
negotiating an extortion fee you know
there's there's kidnapping there's
extortion there's assault and they're
not prosecuted in San Francisco Brooke
Rollins the uh district attorney out
there what is she doing that's where we
hold them accountable using facts and
obvious common sense to our side and not
fall in the same trap that Democrats
dancing oh this is an insurrection
another Insurrection now I mean it's bad
but it's not and January 6 is in Pearl
Harbor
speaking of bad have you guys heard of
this guy we have in charge supposedly of
the Country Joe Biden he is over in
Ireland right now he has Irish Roots so
he's very excited to be in Ireland and
uh here's just a portion of one of his
speeches while there and it's kind of
gross my heart there's nothing our
Nations can't achieve if we do it
together I really mean it so thank you
all God bless you all let's go let's go
late and let the world let's get it done
this is my favorite Biden quote yeah go
ahead I love this yeah just when you
think it can't get any worse or better I
don't know which word to use in this in
this context but that's it by the world
did he mean the ice cream cone like what
is going on here with it you could just
see it he does not know what's about to
come out of his mouth and then in this
case he was able to kind of Bring It
Around but often cannot do it click the
world no it's like you know Molly
station for everybody this is when the
Gavin Newsom is currently making his
like lizard people tour of the United
States it's like what if we did
California government but everywhere
this is the same thing it's like what if
you know what if we did what Biden does
to an ice cream cone but to the whole
world I mean there is this sort of
bizarre I think ultimately Dave you you
must be right that there is something
just kind of you know there's a screw
loose and we've known this for a while
he's sort of daughtering around saying
whatever comes to mind and he doesn't
have the luxury of a Justin Pearson or a
Justin Jones sister take that long
dramatic pause he has to actually like
put words in front of one another and I
just want to say to your point about you
know rhetorical excess you're absolutely
right and I was by the way like kidding
about insurrections you know this is no
no I guess because I use the term
insurrectiony or it's it looks a little
like an Insurrection yeah but that's
where you know you draw the line to be
very clear that this is you know what
happened in Tennessee not now not
January 6th and so forth but yes by all
means right no no no I mean it's not it
it's it's certainly not the thing that
January 6 has been made out to be but
neither was January 6th right very bad
not a thing to do but it wasn't this
like kind of massive inflated and so
there is something to be said I think
um for like for just laughing at these
people because this is I mean Biden the
Jones the Justin Joneses of the world
the Justin Pearsons of the world but
they really get off on most is this
incredible sincerity the gravitas the
just inviolable era of dignity that
you're not ever allowed to question or
or you know even raise an eyebrow at or
you're some kind of anti-American in
insurrectionist right I mean this is
kind of how this stuff works and like if
nothing else for the sake of gallows
humor You Gotta Laugh a little bit when
the president United States says he
wants to to lick the world that's uh
that's pretty good well I'll tell you
guys this I I talked to a guy I know who
lives in Ireland because I just wanted
to get and he's he's very nonpartisan
very objective and I said you know Sean
what is the vibe there in Ireland are
you guys excited to see President Biden
I was asking about the the document
leaks is that overshadowing it and he
said look John um we actually you know
we're very thrilled anytime the American
president comes and I was somewhat
relieved by the fact that foreign
countries still have some respect for
the office at least of the American
president even though this guy is in it
right now which is important but I will
say just to promo my show coming up
today we have the meme Team every Friday
and you guys are always welcome to come
on and join us but one of the memes
we're going to feature today is a one
from Grand Old memes if you're familiar
and it's Joe Biden a mock-up on the
Lincoln Project logo but it's the Lichen
project
that's what we're doing
uh well it's not just uh Joe Biden that
your friend Sean should be happy is in
Ireland right now because Joe brought
another Biden he brought Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden of PornHub and crack
smoking etc etc firing on his possession
the list goes on the laptop let's not
bother with any of that he's now
chilling with his dad in Ireland
basically acting as security so that
when Joe starts wandering off which he
always does Hunter can pull him back in
[Music]
all right come on
so basically he has a at least former
crack addict as his body man I don't
know what he's doing there also Biden's
uh Hunter Biden has gone under no
charges as far as I know for any of the
wrong things that he's done I take it
this doesn't surprise you John
no it doesn't surprise me in the least
and today we're also going to talk about
propublica who's coming after Clarence
Thomas's mom right now 94 years old
because uh Clarence Thomas helped her
sell her house to one of his friends
it's like 194 000 transaction but
there's not a there has not been a peep
from Pro publica about Hunter Biden or
any of these foreign business deals
since right before the South Carolina
2022 Democratic National primary the
point at which all Democrats and media
determined that Joe Biden was
Untouchable but they're going to go
after Clarence Thomas's mom and no
mention about Hunter Biden who allegedly
also had some foreign business deals and
you guessed it Ireland I'm sick and
tired of paying for this guy's trips on
government Jets to go conduct private
business so the Biden family can get
rich I don't know about you
I also am sick of that Spencer you're
right well I mean the flagrancy is the
point I think that's one theme of
everything we've talked about today
right it's supposed to be offensive to
you that Dylan Mulvaney is drinking that
beer it's supposed to be like
extravagantly obviously hypocritical the
way they treat lawmakers and and rioters
in different states it's supposed to be
hypocritical the way they treat Biden
and and Hunter uh versus the way they
treat Clarence Thomas this is a naked
raw Display of Power and you know
whether we are calling it out or
laughing at it or or whatever I do think
we should take it for as understood that
this is the message they want to send we
ought to believe them when they tell us
who they are so that's kind of to me
with all of this stuff especially the
hunter Biden thing which was such an
embarrassing disgusting display on on
the part of our media overlords as well
and part of the New York Times which
took forever to acknowledge that the
story had been unjustly suppressed you
know um we should we should listen to
them when they tell us this about
themselves they genuinely don't think
the rules apply to them no they don't
and you know because we can say bad
words on this show I'm going to say well
I saw Margate from The New York Times
say yesterday on MSNBC with Nicole
Wallace is such the New York
Times The Washington Post they were
refused to address the fact that they
got so much wrong and they won Pulitzer
prizes for their reporting on
Trump and the Russian collusion stuff
and then she goes on MSNBC and lectures
Fox News on what they should and
shouldn't be in terms of journalists
please it's just for the record Mara gay
my audience knows her because she I
forget whether it was in the New York
Times she called me that she said this
was either a white supremacist show or
alt right show I forget which one it was
I mean these people are just clowns
gentlemen I thank you for your time uh
John you've got a show to do in about a
half hour and then this afternoon
Spencer it's a shame you're not in
Florida because John and I are going to
the Miami Beach pier and we're going to
dump giant cases of Bud Light into the
ocean to show those social justice
Warriors what's up
Port which is underwater we can dump it
out there
thank you guys we got a post game show
for everybody else
reubenreport.locals.com start in about
30 seconds and if I don't see you there
have a great weekend we'll be back at it
on Monday we leave you with a cold close
a little more of Joe Biden in Ireland
apparently the dogs aren't thrilled with
him
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]